I'm already feeling inadequate I'm Ben
Affleck this is lad Bible we're here
with the Justice League and we're gonna
answer all your questions no question is
out of bounds the weirdest and the
greatest is that you're your taxi
drivers go to school longer than our
policemen which I find deeply troubling
on a couple levels I mean unless I'm in
a cab in the UK in which I feel really
safe
I'm just already feeling inadequate to
the group I do sometimes get road rage I
have to admit and that's when I wish I
was in the Batmobile because you know
you could just shoot rockets like put
oil slick behind the Sun I would like
that but hope you guys are oh yeah what
cuz I just talk fast for a long time
guys definitely I think I'm ripping some
[ __ ] off on Aquaman telling the truth
you just take my house for some braces
and stuff I thought it'd look pretty
cool so yeah where's the mock what he
was doing guys here eat Billy not on the
biggest unfortunately gonna see too much
of it shot a couple seen amazing that's
true incredible
yeah I'm smaller now than I was Oh put
on 30 pounds for the toe you got a job
we did we did there was a lot of fool
the mistakes though when they tell you
what the Eaton's is very big and husky
and tough look at that
you won't even see any of you any of
this sexy support up to the reveal hey
can I go ahead we just happened to have
a very honest Jason had a base most days
on set I have a hidden talent too which
is I could turn anything into a drum I'm
super power now we're gonna turn this
chair and do a drop and I'm gonna stand
up like this
you gotta get it you better get with it
hey I think we're hurting our cause
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]